the president has a tough decision to
make soon when to open the economy back
up and how MSNBC says Trump is trading
death for dollars
it seems that Republicans that were
making the argument let the World War
two vets die let the Korean War vets die
let the Vietnam vets die let let
everybody in that generation die because
we're worried about Boeing it is the
born it is the weakest among us it is
senior citizens who they're ready to
euthanize because they want Boeing's
corporate earnings to not dip to - too
low
joining me now former Trump White House
chief strategist and host of the war
room pandemic radio show Steve Bannon so
Steve what's the calculation for opening
this back up I think the president I
think you look at what chairman Powell
said this week when he went on TV you've
got to put this virus in back of us and
then open it up that the 2.3 trillion
dollar economic package which took on
the economic crisis that this drop in
aggregate demand has done is is a start
but you have to bridge the whole thing
I'm actually an advocate Jesse and I
think that data will get President Trump
there people should understand he's a
business guy he's very numbers and data
driven I think you're gonna see a big
shift over this weekend where he's going
to sit there and go hey right now we're
going to continue to keep it and maybe
even increase the lock down which I'm a
big advocate of I think in your opening
segment to me was one of the most
powerful things I've seen a media it's
got to be played everywhere if you see
that I think you go to even a harder a
harder lockdown right now a harder
lockdown right now and then we bridge
nobody should lose a job no company
should go out of business we've got a
bridge of small companies the
entrepreneurs to get to the other side
if you have to go through hell go
through it as fast as possible the
president is a wartime president he's
made some tough calls already he shut
down all the traffic coming in from
China any quarantined everybody that
came back and he was criticized by
Morning Joe and Biden those guys as
being races nativists and xenophobic he
is I think he's made the right decisions
I happen to think the numbers show him
where New York's going we're know
orléans is going or where Detroit's
going that we keep this even in a harder
lockdown at least through Easter and
then see where we are your colleague
Steve Hilton I think had a good program
last week but I would disagree in the
fact it's not an either-or
you've got to bridge you've gotten in
Powell said this this week you've got to
bridge the economy to get over this
chasm I think President Trump is going
to come to the conclusion hey I want to
even tighten this thing up some more so
that we can get through this quicker and
faster and have a steeper have a steeper
revival and I think that's what I
believe that's what's going to happen I
think it's the right thing to happen all
right I think you're right about that